when it comes to pedestrians and cars
it's really important to know who has
the right-of-way in different scenarios
in today's legal minute Eric Palacios
from Eric Palacios and Associates the
sponsors of this segment talks about the
laws regarding pedestrians and their
right-of-way
I'm attorney Eric Palacios welcome to
the legal minute today's question is
when do pedestrians have the right of
way
see a pedestrian in a crosswalk you have
to yield the right-of-way to that person
pedestrians must cross with the signal
or light if there is one if a pedestrian
is crossing where there is no crosswalk
or not at an intersection The Pedestrian
must then yield to traffic it's
important to note that just because you
have the right of way doesn't mean that
you can run over a pedestrian you can
have the right-of-way and still be
liable for hitting someone if you could
have avoided the Collision if you have
any legal questions please call us at
702-444-7777
you can call Palacios and Associates at
that number that was mentioned or visit
their website at Eric palacioslaw.com